TEAM, I VEER TCCINE R TO B OS  '
I E TO BIN  AND IY'ALL JU TRESPH
A POLNGT ABOUE NBA. MY LIFEHATO
DON'T  I'M
I'GOTOS GAME
FOR A VACCINMANDAT STAYING
Y
N.T GUEST ISAN NBAD ANN VOCATE
SIX- CHALL OF FAMER,ARABDUL-JAB
FEED IN A PSA SHOWG HIM
GETTING KS FORT
>> CAND AT H DO WHAT WHAT FEACTH
CA OTHER PEOPLE.S GOOD THI
HITEAMMATES, THEIR
AND THE OTHER PEOPLE THAT WORK
.
HE'S GOING  BM VACCINAT,
BEING A GOAND HE HASATES ANDHAI
TOSTAND IT.
TO THE ET THHECA
MASKING ANVAIONS H PROVEN TO
THAT.
W AT
IT'S A TOUGH ISSUE BECAUSE YOU
KNOW, IN PEOPLE
OUT THERE WANT TO YOU KNOW,
HIM THE SPACE TO FIGURE THIS
T, BUT THE SEASON IS UPO. OUT O.
WHAT DO YOU IMAGINE IS G OTHISAM
I ASSUME THEY'RE STA O TOUGH  A
APPROACH TO DEALING TH
RIGH TTOUGH LOVE I W THEM
BECAUSE THEY'VE  THI
IM A TRYING TO AT I
O ACCE
RIGHT EMBRACE HIM AS HEROD OF S.
RET DONALD
TRYRIEUST RE THAN KAERNICKD.
ER CGRE SPICERSHE SAYS THELET M
COVID SHOTEZTHESE ARE THE PEOPLA
SU, SHOULDN' AS ?
UNDERSTT HE'S PEO
HIMSWITH.
IT MATY'AND WEANE THATE TO PROTO
TO GO TO GRADE HOHE TO BE INOT
SO IF  AWARE OTA
VS
IN TERMS OF KNOWLEDG OF WLEM I
.S O ATED L JAMES.
H TOUND NG VACCINATED.
OFERT OFCOVERAGE A SOM
THESE FOLKS HAVE DECLINEPUBLICL
ARE YOU DISAPPOINTEDN SOME OS A
HAS THAT BR PLATFORM?
OLE IN THIS DO YOU
THINK?>> LeBRON HAS THE
DISCONN ISSUESE FEELS E IMR LeB
HE'S NOT MAKING A BI
OOHEPLE THATN
HIS FE
BE SEASON. TO Y
ITTASTARTED.
Y HE'S
SUPPOSED TO BE FOCUSHE TAKEN T Y
OFOI ACCINATIONSD WEARING MASKS.
>> I WANTO TALK
ANOTHER ISSUE YOU'VE BEEN RYVOCC
PEOPLE CANA PIECE RENT
STACKS, HE WAY.REAT THAT YOU HAE
ANONS OFWI
'60s AND 's WITH A BLACK COP
WHAT HAPPENED R ITE  SPLIFTING.T
>> IT NG, DIDN'T FEELG
WITH.
BORN  S CROW AN I
DIDN'T FEE WAS
SOMETHINSHD  COPE WITH.
ANT NDSHE OUT OF THE
ON THE OUT.COVA BID OF BREAD.
TANOTHER
TIME, MY, E D WHATM WAS WITHY  W
OMETIMESSCN  AFFECT YO YOUR LIF.
COREGOYTT NOW.
THOSE S,EFT
WHATRETS? WL, YOU KNOHAUALLY WH.
POLITICAL WILYN EN
>> AUTUESTIOABIT.
EEABDUL-JABBAR.
THANKS FOR SWI TJOIN UAN
IMPORT